foreign
[Music]
here in this video we will showcase the
location of the deadly monsters and
other creatures of Middle Earth we will
take you from one monster location to
another so let's get to it
let's start with what monsters we can
find in the frigid Northern lands of
followed with in here we will stumble
over a subspecies of cave trolls called
the snow troll which are large
semi-senting bees over 15 to 20 feet
tall there could be more wild monsters
in the depths of the mountains of
forward weight like goblins and nameless
creatures but none are mentioned
then just a few leaks to the southeast
we come to the evil lands of angma and a
dreaded mountain called gundabad from
the forges and the underground realm of
this ancient Fortress slash Caverns We
Gather strange ogres the gun about ogres
a unique species of wolves called walks
seen in The Hobbit and a swamp species
of man-sized giant bats
south of angma we have the lost kingdom
of Honor which was one of the most
powerful of the Dunedin kingdoms here a
strange species of stone trolls are seen
they are met by Bilbo in the company of
Thorin and the dwarves the exact
location of where these trolls were
found is called the troll Shores that
are close by the Misty Mountains located
between the rivers in the rudar region
so to the ears of the Drone shows we
have the aforementioned Misty Mountains
and here there are tons of creatures to
be found starting with the goblins and a
big Goblin King in the northern part of
the mountain range inside the Deep
Caverns outside there are the stone
giants the mountain Giants the big ones
as well as the great Eagles who have an
Airy just east of the mountains
when we go a little bit down south in
the same mountain range we come to the
caves of Moria and here as we have seen
in The Fellowship of the Ring there are
cave trolls and goblins then in The
Hobbit we find out that it is where as
of the defiler initially rule
there's also a nameless being called The
Watcher in the water which lurks near
the Western gate but the most deadly
monster found in the depths of Moria is
a balrog of morgoth notably called
duren's Bane
so going towards the southern end of the
Misty Mountains we come into fangon
forests which can be said that lies in
the foothills of the mountain range here
we meet the tree-like entities called
the ends and a bit South at the end of
the range is eisengard and here's
Saruman bred a new type of urubhai which
are all men hybrids and also a unique
breed of walks which are large wolf-like
creatures only found in eisengard
anyway from there we come back North we
travel into another location and we are
back in the northernmost part of the map
here we have the withered Heath and the
northern ways which are home to cold
Drakes a species of dragon which cannot
breathe fire we also find that in the
cold deserts here
it is home to the gigantic Subterranean
wheel worms as was seen in the Battle of
the Five Armies
to itself we have the plains of the
rovanin which are also called the
wilderlands and it is here that the
shape-shifting Bayonne makes this home
which is also near the Great Falls of
merkwood to its ease and the area of the
great Eagles to its West on the Eastern
Edge we come to Erebor the Lonely
Mountain West small made his lair to
dwell in underneath piles of gold
so a bit south of that is the Greenwood
the largest forested land in Middle
Earth and in the third age it became
known as merkwood which Bears the
location of dog guldur in its southern
part and in this evil Fortress we find
the giant spiders and also the place
where the truncated troll the Catapult
Troll and the war trolls are bred for
battle all the three types of trolls
were seen in The Hobbit the Battle of
the Five Armies
now from dogaldur if we keep traveling
to the South we pass by the brown lands
and the dead marshes and we gradually
come to the dark lands of Mordor where
the dark lord Sauron himself lies in the
tower of baradur they are also the
dreaded Phelps which makes the dark
lands the entire Place their habitat and
also we can find large mountain trolls
most notably Manning the black gates in
the northern part of Mordor
so still in this cursed Lan but on the
Eastern flank we find a dead City also
known as Minas morgul whereby the ring
raids led by the witch king of angmar
makes it their home in the third age
on the mountain slopes of Minas morgul
is a staircase into Mordor where a giant
spider called shielop is found who is an
offspring of the angolian
so now coming out of this place and if
we travel to the edge of the map in the
South the land that we come to is called
harat or the land of the haradrim where
the great Siege bees are found the same
ones which were dragging the battering
ram groan in the third Lord of the Rings
movie The Return of the King in these
lands we also find the large mummy kills
the oliphons of Middle Earth who were
bred into war bees by the haradrim
themselves
so all right with that we covered all
the monsters in Middle Earth that was
seen in the third age but to do West is
a very big expanse of ocean and it is
known as the sundering sea where the
ancient continent of valerian was once
situated which was destroyed by the
Creator eru ilivitar in the depths are
many creatures such as the sea serpent
which although wasn't mentioned in any
of the books but was only seen in the
rings of power could still be considered
Canon since most of the maps of Middle
Earth depicts a sea serpent in the
oceans
so traveling back in time to the first
age in Earth's wild Valerian which was
destroyed in the first age are the
dragon's glaurum scatter and and galagon
the black were all bred and made in the
northern part called angban in the
volcanic mountains of tangorodrim even
the bell rocks with gothmok as the
leader was situated in the iron prison
of angban to the east of tangoradrim in
the North
and now we come to the last of the
monsters in this list which also
happened to be the first Monster to
awaken in the world of Middle Earth the
angolian even though not knowing where
it actually came from but after breaking
off in the alliance with margoth she
fled to the mountains of Nan durgathab
and made it her home breeding a new
generation of spiders and ultimately
feeding on herself to death
so those are the locations of all the
monsters of Middle Earth I hope you have
enjoyed watching this video do hit the
like button for support and subscribe
smash the Bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam